[Music]
um so this isn't really a secret it's
more of a life update
uh recently i've been through a breakup
and i got a ticket
for having an open container
and
it's really emotional because it's my
first one that's really serious and i
feel myself as like
a really good person and really
responsible
and i've been really hard on myself
and i feel like i'm
losing part of myself
it's hard to just keep going every
single day just
saying like no you got it just get it
done just do what you got to do
so yeah i hope that this helps somebody
to not feel like they're alone and that
they can get through stuff
[Music]
i act like being adopted doesn't bother
me but i miss my biological parents
every day even though i don't know them
[Music]
so my secret is um
i know 100 that i married my husband
just because i was pregnant and i wasn't
actually in love with him
we're coming up on our three-year
wedding anniversary and i'm still not in
love with him and i really don't know
what to do and it really makes me sad
for my son and myself
[Music]
a secret i have and it's usually a
secret that most
well most parents look down and most
people say like well what are you going
to do is a secret that
i truly want to do nothing in life like
i have no sense of direction
because
most people in my life told me that i've
i'm pretty directionalist and my mom
always tells me that i just don't really
tend to follow things i'm usually my own
person but
because of that i just usually feel like
i'm just i just don't want to do
anything
[Music]
i wish i'd never gotten any tattoos i
think it's limited my freedom
to
grow outside of myself i think too much
about them and how people think about
them and how i think about them
[Music]
okay
um
i don't really know how to say this
properly but
i don't know how to tell my brother that
the only reason i'm still here is
because of him
and
i really really really don't think i
would have made it through the past
couple years if he wasn't there but i'm
scared he's going to
be weirded out by how close i feel to
him
[Music]
hold your horses this one's gonna be
crazy
just kidding no it's pretty simple um
i'm really huge on surprises
and i absolutely love surprises i love
to surprise other people
but the unfortunate part about being
that person
nobody surprises you so one of the
hugest secrets
that i would love to have
is a surprise birthday party
for myself
so um but i can't freaking tell people
hey i need you to throw me a surprise
birthday party but yeah secretly i'm a
person living wishing that someone i'm
dying for someone to throw me my own
surprise birthday party
[Music]
okay so my secret is that even though my
boyfriend has not yet proposed i have
already purchased my wedding dress
and my veil and secured a photographer
for the engagement shoot
the end
[Music]
when i was a little kid i lived with my
grandmother and they always had roaches
and one day my dad walked in and i was
eating a roach
okay
[Music]
um my secret is that
i've liked guys my entire life but
recently i keep getting crushes on girls
and i'm not sure how to flirt
[Music]
my secret is when i turned 18 i was
scared about how i was going to pay for
college so
i made an account on a sugar daddy
website
and acquired four sugar daddies
[Music]
and it never turned sexual but i got
paid 200 every time i would send them an
email
and now i'm married not to a sugar daddy
but still
[Music]
sometimes when i see people on the
street i want to hit them in the face
[Music]
sometimes i wonder if there is a god
i'm not really sure where i'll be in a
year from now
[Music]
i'm scared i'll never be able to love
anyone ever
i
have never loved anyone like been in
love before and i don't know i thought
at this point in my life i would
[Music]
i do have a secret
i've been attempting to try to
allow my heart to get over someone
and i don't know how to let him go
but i have met someone new
he doesn't know
the extent of my feelings for this other
person
that i've practically been waiting for
[Music]
okay
um
my secret is that
i
struggle with a binge eating disorder
and i haven't told anyone because i'm
embarrassed
and i don't know how to get help
[Music]
i
am scared that i resent my dad for
everything he's put me through but i
still love him so i don't really know
how to
interact with him i guess it's hard
because i feel like i started seeing him
more as a man rather than my dad so what
like all the choices that he makes i
kind of
see like him doing it as a man
disrespecting women rather than like my
dad picking up if that makes sense
uh hello um
recently i just got off deployment
i was in port
in hawaii
almost home
and then
my wife she
took all my money and then told me she
wanted a divorce
and then three days later i got a call
my sister was in the hospital
and uh she wanted to take her own life
and so now i'm here
it's what like six days later
[Music]
and yeah that's it
[Music]
um i've never told any or at least i've
never told him on this but she saved my
life last year when i was in a deep like
a very dark place and she just called me
to tell me she was very proud of me out
of the blue and that she loved me
and that i was one of the greatest gifts
that she's ever had in this life and
with that call i
like my entire perspective on my own
life changed and she saved my life
[Music]
i fell in love with my best friends
during seventh grade and the weekend
i had finally worked up the courage to
say my feelings to him i walked into the
school on monday and found out that he
had died
on that saturday
and i've
never truly gotten over it
because
i've always been afraid that someone i
love or someone i care about will be
gone before i have the chance to do
anything with them so
that just leads to so much unrest and
pressure that i've never been able to
release
[Music]
[Music]
you